It's amusing, after your morning coffee
or tea,
to start tapping on the cup with your spoon.
It's pretty much the same pitch everywhere,
tun-tun-tun, whatever it is, and then maybe
it's the characteristic pitch of this
cup, and if you take another cup and
another spoon, for that matter, maybe you
get a different sound.
Who knows? So maybe it's always the same
pitch from this particular cup
if tapped by this spoon. But then, I started tapping
somewhere else.
Those four points emit a common pitch,
And those four points also emit a common pitch,
but a higher pitch than those four
points. We'll explore what's causing this,
but you might first think that it has to
do with the handle. That seems to be a very
suspicious culprit, and thank you very
much for pointing that out too.
Of course it has to do with the handle, but-- if it
has to do with the handle, wouldn't you have
thought that this half closer to the handle
and this half farther from the handle
should behave differently?
But that's not how the symmetry is broken.
Indeed, the point next to the handle and point
farthest from the handle
behave exactly the same way. Whereas 45 degrees
off, you get the higher pitch.
It has to do with the handle, perhaps, but the symmetry-breaking pattern is not so naive
as we at first thought. Let's understand what's
happening, and in order to do this we'll
break it up in two stages. First, we'll
understand why any quadruplet of four
points that form the vertices of a
square always give you the same pitch,
a common pitch, and then we'll understand why
this quadruplet emits a
higher pitch than those four points.
Okay, so let's forget about the handle. So
the handle-- pretend the handle's not there.
When we tap this point, we are making this point
vibrate. We're setting it in motion
like this.
Well, roughly speaking,
the point diametrically opposite can
react in one of the two ways. When this
point is doing that, the other point can
go like this,
Or go like this. We say in phase
or out of phase. Now, this reaction--
this response-- is essentially moving the
cup back and forth, back and forth,
sliding it as a total rigid body, as a
whole body, and it does not really (to a good approximation) deform the cup.
But, of course, the sound has to do with the
deformation of the cup, how it's vibrating altogether.
So, so this is not producing
sound-- that's not what you're hearing--
what you're hearing is this response
when this point moves back and forth
this goes in and out and at the same
time like this
- Professor, why does that make a sound, by the way?
- Because sound means that somebody
(for example, it can be your throat, it
can be for example birds chirping,
it can be a cup chiming) is vibrating very, very
fast and shaking air around it, and when you
shake the air like this
the air next to it gets compressed and
bounces off because the air has some
elasticity, and then that bounce compresses the
next part of the air and bounces off
and there's a wave that propagates like
this towards the camera and eventually
reaches the ear and inside the eardrum
this wave is shaking the eardrum and
that's what you hear as a sound. Okay. So the
vibration and deformation ultimately, of
the very rapid deformation of the cup, is
producing the sound. And this response is not
really deforming the cup, whereas this one
is, so. And this is what's primarily
responsible for the sound. On the other
hand, the cup as a whole doesn't want to
change its volume if it can help it, it
wants to stay as incompressible as
possible. In other words, when those two go in, well,
by reaction these two are pushed out
in order to keep the same volume, and if
these go out these two are pulled in so that
you get this kind of rhombus-type oscillation, pum-pum-pum-pum-pum, and that's why any
quadruplet of four points that form the vertices of a square always sing in unison.
It doesn't matter which of the four
points you start exciting, all the other
three follow, and four together go into
this losange
or rhombus vibration. Well, so we now
understand why this quadruplet of points and
this quadruplet of points each
emits a common pitch. Now, why this
quadruplet of points are higher-pitched than this
quadruplet of points are lower-pitched--
in order to understand that we must
resurrect the handle that we have been
neglecting so far. So the handle comes back.
You see, when-- let's say that we
excite one of the four points, those,
those four points. As we saw, it doesn't
matter which of the four points you
excite because all of them work in
unison. When those four points are
vibrating together, they have to take the
handle, drag the handle with them, because
you see, one of the points, vibrating points, is attached to the handle, so the
handle must move back and forth while
those four points are vibrating. In contrast
when those four points are made to vibrate,
you remember what happens-- when this goes in,
this goes out and this goes in,
this goes out. The point just in between is
what we call a node. In other words, to a
good approximation, it's stationary,
it doesn't move in between, so as far as these
quadruplet of points are concerned,
the handle is invisible-- it's as if the hand
were not there because it's attached to
a point that's not doing any vibration, vibrational
motion. So we now have two
elastic systems-- you can think of them as
springs if you like-- this one and this one.
One of them is attached to some heavy
mass that he has to drag along; the other
one is not attached to anything because
this is invisible to those four points.
And they are made of the same stiff material that is the cup. So imagine two
springs, one of them is attached to a heavy mass, the other one is not attached
to a heavy mass, and when you let them go what you
hear-- the heavy one goes *wmmm*
[imitates low-frequency oscillations]
in a very sluggish way, whereas the back
goes hee-ho, hee-ho, and that's the difference of the
pitch that we hear. And that is why these four points
emit a low pitch whereas those four
points emit the higher pitch. So far, we saw
where the handle was and we try to figure out
what this sound pattern was like. The
inverse problem is also interesting
by which I mean, since we're talking
about the pitch of the sound that we hear,
let's imagine ourselves in a pitch dark
room. Say that we walk into this room.
We don't know where the handle is, but
imagine that we are allowed to go around
the cup, tapping it everywhere, and record the sound
pattern that we get from each point.
From that recorded data of the sound pattern
can we reconstruct where the handle was?
That is the inverse problem. A bit more
abstractly speaking, instead of saying
that we know the cause and then by
solving whatever mathematical model,
partial differential equations, whatnot,
you try to predict what the effect
is going to be, we are going the other
direction. We have this observed data,
effects if you like, which we know to be
true, I mean, we just see this, and we
then try to figure out what on earth is
causing, is responsible for the
production of this effect. So this is the
inverse problem rather than our forward
problem. And if you think about it much
of the scientific endeavor is really
about solving an inverse problem. We
wanted to get to the bottom of things,
want to recover the cause, and this very,
very simple everyday morning breakfast
example shows that the inverse problem
is not always naively solvable. Indeed
you probably agree with me that if I
took a cup and rotated 90 degrees, the
basic pattern that we hear
in a north-south-east-west and so on and
in between will be the same.
We don't know where the handle is up to
90 degree rotation. You can be here, here,
here, here. So we can narrow it down to
four possible positions
Yes. Well, okay, so there is some sort of
ambiguity, you know, as regards the
position because the handle can be here or
here or here or here and you'll get the same
pattern of the noise. But there's
something even worse.
You can't even tell the number of handles
because instead of having a large handle
here you could have two maybe medium
handles, and you agree that the pattern
of the vibration will be the same, or
indeed four small handles here and here
and here and you'd probably get still the
same, what we call the ground state or the
same kind of vibration pattern. So you
can't even tell the number of handles
and you can't tell the position of handles
but up to symmetry, you can actually
start saying something and this is a
very typical solution in the
typical situation. You wanted to "mod out"-- you have to sort of neglect and
somehow take out this mentally and then start solving the problem. Anyway, so this
very simple example shows that the
universal problem is on the whole not always
solvable. But you can actually say
something when you sort of start
handling the symmetry in a clever way.
- If we turned the lights out, and I was
trying to figure out the cup, can I do it?
- We in general can't, but we can
say something up to symmetry. You know,
we know that for example there aren't three handles because that would break the symmetry in
a completely different manner. In fact,
ever since I noticed this phenomenon
I've been looking for a cup with 3 handles
because that would be very interesting
and recently a friend of mine, Brian
White of Stanford, got me 2 cups
and one of them has three handles. Now, I'm--
unfortunately it's not a very nice cup
in-- I mean, it is a very
beautiful cup-- but for our purposes, for our
purposes it's not a very well-performing
cup because it doesn't really chime nicely.
And in between.
So it's somewhat interesting, I
mean, those three points
and those three points in between emit
a common pitch, but in between...
I'm not sure that I can do this. You can't
really hear the difference.
It's a very very small difference.
Yeah. So in between there's a slight
rising of the pitch that I'd like to
hear more clearly, so we need a larger
cup right away. And this is a very choppy
chunky mug from Stanford's math department,
but if you take a really well-made thin
and delicate china cup, this chime is so much more beautiful, so I recommend it.
Arrows 3. Well, it's 3 to the 3 to the 3. You ain't seen
nothing yet. OK, so
here we go, 3, 4 arrows, one more arrow.
Well, what does this mean? 3, 3 arrows of 3, 3
arrows...